All right. Let's play with some of these substitutions, in practice.
All right, here we are, back in that simple text file--
the play HTML file I was playing with before--
and we're going to use this because it's a little bit quicker
to demonstrate what I'd like to talk about.
So I'm going to enter some text.
So I've typed in some text; I Save it this and I load this in my browser.
Okay. So here we are; I've loaded this text in my browser
and, if you remember--if I just type in plain text in an HTML file,
it just shows up as plain text in the browser.
Okay. Now I'm going to surround this tag with angled brackets
and let's see how this renders in our browser.
When I Reload my browser,
that word, html, disappeared.
That's because, when I put angled brackets around it,
it turned into a tag, and tags don't render an HTML.
They turn into tags.
So if we use the Escaping we just learned
and I replace this Less Than symbol with our Escape,
which is: <
and I replace the Greater Than with: >
and I Reload this in my browser, what we see is
the actual text that we wanted to demonstrate--
which is the actual angled brackets.
So let's try another quick example of this.
If I were to change the string, html,
to the letter, "b",
and Save this and Reload this in my browser,
we now have the tag.
And if I were to go back to my Editor and change
these Less Than's and Greater Than's
back into the actual < and >,
and Reload this in my browser,
our text turns to bold.
So if we don't want our HTML to behave as HTML, we need to Escape it.
And if we want it to behave as HTML--we don't Escape it.
All right. Try some Escaping on your own.
So what is the correct way to include the text:
& = & in rendered HTML?
So it should look like this once it's rendered in the browser.
What do we need to include in the HTML to get that ?